Tire Discounter Group! Re-deliver! Until May 31st, receive up to $100 back by mail and rebate when you buy four new eligible Michelin tires. Conditions apply. See dealer or michelin.ca for details. Find a Michelin Tire dealer by visiting Tire Discounter Group's TreadExperts dealer locator at tirediscountergroup.ca slash locations.
Tire Discounter Group！再次送货！在5月31日前，购买四条符合条件的全新米其林轮胎，即可通过邮寄和返利获得最高100美元的现金回馈。受条件限制。详情请咨询经销商或访问michelin.ca。访问Tire Discounter Group的TreadExperts经销商定位器 tirediscountergroup.ca/locations，查找米其林轮胎经销商。
Tire Discounter Group, tirediscountergroup.ca Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. When 22-year-old Lisan Froon told her parents she was planning a six-week trip to Costa Rica, they kept their concerns to themselves. The Froon family lived in the Dutch city of Amersfoort and had never been outside of Europe.
Tire Discounter Group，tirediscountergroup.ca。我们的节目涉及严肃且往往令人不安的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您应用中或我们网站上本集的节目说明。当22岁的莉桑·弗伦（Lisan Froon）告诉父母她计划去哥斯达黎加进行为期六周的旅行时，他们把担忧藏在了心里。弗伦一家住在荷兰的阿默斯福特市，此前从未离开过欧洲。
With relatively little travel experience, Lisan's parents had reservations about their only daughter venturing to a foreign country, but they wanted to be supportive. Lisan had been struggling with self-confidence, and a step outside her comfort zone could be exactly what she needed. Besides, Lisan was a sensible, intelligent and introspective young woman who preferred nature and sports over partying. She gave her family no reason to worry. When the trip unexpectedly fell through, Lisan's parents breathed the collective sigh of relief. But that relief was short-lived. Before long, Lassane announced the plan was back in action, but the destination had been changed.
由于旅行经验相对较少，莉桑的父母对他们唯一的女儿去往异国他乡心存顾虑，但他们还是想给予支持。莉桑一直缺乏自信，走出舒适区可能正是她所需要的。此外，莉桑是一个理智、聪明且内省的年轻女性，比起聚会，她更喜欢大自然和运动。她没有给家人任何担心的理由。当旅行意外取消时，莉桑的父母集体松了一口气。但这种宽慰是短暂的。没过多久，莉桑宣布计划重新启动，但目的地变了。
She would be going to the neighbouring country of Panama instead. In the lead-up to the trip, Lassane sat her parents and older brother down and ran them through every step of her upcoming journey. She would be travelling with her close friend, 21-year-old Chris Cramer's, a fine arts student with a flair for performing. The two had met four years prior while working at the same restaurant, and they'd recently moved into a shared house together. Chris had fallen in love with Latin America during a family vacation to Peru. Since then, she'd fantasised about returning to the continent to study Spanish. Chris was extroverted, creative,
她将改去邻国巴拿马。在旅行前夕，莉桑让父母和哥哥坐下来，向他们详细介绍了即将到来的旅程的每一步。她将与密友、21岁的克里斯·克雷默（Chris Kremers）同行，克里斯是一位有表演天赋的美术系学生。两人四年前在同一家餐厅工作时相识，最近还搬进了合租房。克里斯在一次去秘鲁的家庭度假中爱上了拉丁美洲。从那时起，她就幻想回到这片大陆学习西班牙语。克里斯性格外向、富有创造力，
and outgoing, complimenting Lissane's quieter and more reserved personality. The two friends had a shared vision. They didn't just want a simple vacation through typical tourist traps, they wanted a special trip, one that held significance. They'd spend two weeks in the coastal Panamanian town of Bocas del Toro, exploring the beaches while taking Spanish classes. Then it was on to the mountain region of Boquete where they'd immerse themselves in the local culture and language and do some volunteer work at a daycare centre. Lissane's brother deemed it unnecessary for his sister to go through their plans in such detail but that's just the kind of person she was, organised to a tee. As the big day approached, Lisan was apprehensive yet excited. Having spent the past few years
且开朗，与莉桑安静、内敛的性格形成了互补。两位朋友有着共同的愿景。她们不仅仅想要一次简单的、走马观花的旅游，她们想要一次特别的、有意义的旅行。她们将在巴拿马沿海小镇博卡斯德尔托罗（Bocas del Toro）度过两周，在参加西班牙语课程的同时探索海滩。然后前往博克特（Boquete）山区，在那里沉浸于当地文化和语言，并在一家日托中心做志愿者。莉桑的哥哥认为妹妹没必要把计划讲得这么详细，但她就是那种人，做事井井有条。随着大日子的临近，莉桑既忐忑又兴奋。过去几年里，她一直
working part time while studying for her degree in Applied Psychology, she was ready for an adventure. The departing flight was scheduled for March 15, 2014. When the day came, Lisan checked in at Amsterdam's Skiphole Airport and stood waiting with her parents. Chris Kramer's was running late. With each passing minute, the ever-punctual Lisan grew more anxious. Lisan's parents reassured her that Chris would arrive any moment. While they too had been nervous about the trip, they now gazed at their daughter with nothing but pride and admiration. When Chris finally arrived, Lassan's anxiety gave way to excitement. Peter Froon embraced his daughter into a tight bear hug. Make the most of it, her mother
一边兼职一边攻读应用心理学学位，她已经准备好迎接冒险了。出发航班定于2014年3月15日。当天，莉桑在阿姆斯特丹史基浦机场办理了登机手续，和父母一起等待。克里斯·克雷默迟到了。随着时间一分一秒过去，一向准时的莉桑变得越来越焦虑。莉桑的父母安慰她说克里斯很快就会到。虽然他们也曾对这次旅行感到紧张，但现在他们看着女儿，心中只有骄傲和赞赏。当克里斯终于到达时，莉桑的焦虑变成了兴奋。彼得·弗伦给了女儿一个紧紧的拥抱。“好好享受吧，”她母亲
said. In high spirits, the two friends took off down the long hallway leading to their flight. Just before they disappeared from view, Lassane turned around and waved a final goodbye. At that moment, Peter relaxed. It was clear to him that his daughter no longer had any hesitations. She was ready. The four parents decided to grab a quick coffee together. This was the first time they'd ever met, and with their daughters embarking on such a major adventure together, it was suggested that they exchange phone numbers. Surely they'd never need to use them, but just in case. For Chris Cramerz and Lassane Froon, the trip started out like a dream. After overcoming the shock of jet lag, they spent the first leg of their journey embracing the tropical heat and
说道。兴高采烈的两位朋友沿着通往航班的长廊走去。在她们消失在视线中之前，莉桑转过身挥手作了最后的告别。那一刻，彼得放松了下来。他清楚地看到女儿不再有任何犹豫。她准备好了。四位家长决定一起去喝杯咖啡。这是他们第一次见面，考虑到女儿们正一起踏上一场如此重大的冒险，有人建议他们交换电话号码。当然，他们可能永远用不上，但以防万一。对于克里斯·克雷默和莉桑·弗伦来说，这段旅程开始得就像一场梦。在克服了时差带来的冲击后，她们旅程的第一站沉浸在热带的炎热和
Caribbean lifestyle of Bocas del Toro. They took Spanish classes, went island hopping and hung out with fellow travellers. They snorkelled, danced in a tropical rainstorm and ate incredible food. It was unlike anything they'd ever experienced. After a day trip to the nearby Zapatea island, Lassane wrote in her diary, After a day trip to the nearby Zapotea island, Lassane wrote in her diary, I could not believe my eyes. It was one big paradise. Exactly like in your dreams. Even a temporary stomach bug couldn't keep Chris's spirits down. As their time in Bocas del Toro drew to an end, she struggled to say goodbye. "'The time we had in Bocas was really amazing,' Chris wrote in her diary.
博卡斯德尔托罗的加勒比生活方式中。她们上了西班牙语课，去跳岛游，并与旅伴们聚在一起。她们浮潜、在热带暴雨中跳舞，还吃了美味的食物。这是她们从未体验过的。在去往附近的萨帕蒂亚岛（Zapatea）一日游后，莉桑在日记中写道：“我简直不敢相信自己的眼睛。这是一个巨大的天堂。就像梦里一样。”即使是暂时的肠胃不适也没能压下克里斯的兴致。随着在博卡斯德尔托罗的时间接近尾声，她很难说再见。“我们在博卡斯度过的时光真的很棒，”克里斯在日记中写道。
"'We really had a holiday there. I have never seen a place with such a beautiful coastline and palm trees and such. Really super.'" Chris and Lassane arrived in Boquete on Saturday March 29, 2014. Located in the western province of Chiriquí, just 60 kilometres from the Costa Rican border, Boquete is a quaint mountain town known for its hiking trails, waterfalls, coffee plantations and lush scenery. At 1200 metres above sea level, the cooler climate makes it a popular destination for tourists seeking nature and outdoor adventure. With a significant
“我们在那里真的度过了一个假期。我从未见过拥有如此美丽的海岸线、棕榈树之类的地方。真的超级棒。”克里斯和莉桑于2014年3月29日星期六抵达博克特。博克特位于奇里基省西部，距离哥斯达黎加边境仅60公里，是一个古朴的山城，以其徒步小径、瀑布、咖啡种植园和郁郁葱葱的风景而闻名。海拔1200米，凉爽的气候使其成为寻求自然和户外探险的游客的热门目的地。凭借着庞大的
expat community, Boquete promised Lasanne and Chris a unique experience without being too far off the beaten path. The young women had arranged to stay with a local family who rented out rooms to international guests. Not only did this suit their budget, it allowed them a genuine insight into local life. But this culture shock quickly proved overwhelming for Lisan. On the night of their arrival, she confided in her diary that she wanted to go home. Although the place was beautiful and the host family was friendly, Lassane felt that the switch from vacation mode to living the real life of a real Panamanian was
外籍人士社区，博克特为莉桑和克里斯提供了一种独特的体验，同时又不会过于偏僻。这两位年轻女性安排住在一位向国际游客出租房间的当地家庭中。这不仅符合她们的预算，还让她们能真正深入了解当地生活。但这种文化冲击很快让莉桑感到难以承受。抵达当晚，她在日记中吐露自己想回家。虽然这个地方很美，寄宿家庭也很友好，但莉桑觉得从度假模式切换到真正的巴拿马人生活
too much. She wrote, "...I was way too naive to think that I could handle this. I'm in way over my head. I want mum and dad to hold me tight and tell me that everything will be alright. But I can't let them know how I feel now because I don't want them to worry. I thought I should be able to do this, the final test before I can be really happy with myself. So far, I have failed badly." Chris wrote about struggling to adapt to the new environment as well, but after a decent night's sleep, both women were in better spirits. They spent the next day exploring the town and checking
太难了。她写道：“……我太天真了，以为自己能应付这一切。我完全力不从心。我想让妈妈和爸爸紧紧抱住我，告诉我一切都会好起来的。但我现在不能让他们知道我的感受，因为我不想让他们担心。我以为我应该能做到这一点，这是我在真正对自己感到满意之前的最后考验。到目前为止，我失败得很惨。”克里斯也写到了努力适应新环境的挣扎，但在睡了一个好觉后，两人的精神状态都好多了。她们花了一整天时间探索小镇并查看
out some tours advertised in the local Spanish school. Months prior to leaving the Netherlands, they'd arranged to volunteer at a boquete children's centre called Aura Daycare. Both friends were looking forward to it immensely. But when they arrived at Aura on Monday March 31, they didn't get the warm welcome they anticipated. The staff weren't expecting the pair for another week and had no use for them in the meantime. Put off by the cold treatment they received, Chris wrote in her diary, Today was a strange day. We don't really want to go back to Aura anymore because we didn't feel welcome at all there and it was really a huge disappointment. Lissane's diary entry was more succinct. Yuck, yuck, yuck, she wrote. Our first
当地西班牙语学校宣传的一些旅游项目。在离开荷兰的几个月前，她们就安排好在一家名为Aura日托中心的博克特儿童中心做志愿者。两位朋友都非常期待。但当她们在3月31日星期一到达Aura时，并没有得到预期的热烈欢迎。工作人员并没有预料到她们会提前一周到来，暂时也用不上她们。由于受到了冷遇，克里斯在日记中写道：“今天真是奇怪的一天。我们真的不想再回Aura了，因为我们根本没感觉到受欢迎，这真是巨大的失望。”莉桑的日记条目更简洁。“恶心，恶心，恶心，”她写道。“我们的第一
day was a disaster. In an attempt to shake off their disappointment, the young women went to the Spanish school to discuss alternative volunteer projects. They found another they liked the sound of and hoped they could begin in the next couple of days. While they waited for a response from the volunteer coordinator, they treated themselves to a massage. Chris wrote, Let's hope that the other project is really fun. Let's go with the Panamanian flow. On the morning of Wednesday April 2, 2014, Boquete tour guide Feliciano Gonzalez stood
天简直是一场灾难。”为了摆脱失望，这两位年轻女性去了西班牙语学校讨论其他的志愿者项目。她们找到了另一个听起来不错的项目，并希望能在接下来的几天内开始。在等待志愿者协调员回复的同时，她们去做了按摩。克里斯写道：“希望另一个项目真的很有趣。让我们顺其自然吧。”2014年4月2日星期三早上，博克特导游费利西亚诺·冈萨雷斯（Feliciano Gonzalez）站在
at the Spanish school waiting for Lisanne Froon and Chris Cramer. The previous morning, the Dutch tourists had booked a tour with Feliciano to visit a nearby farm. A German woman named Eileen who worked at the Spanish school also decided to join them. But as the minutes ticked by, there was no sign of Lisan and Chris. Feliciano knew the young women were staying with a host family who lived just a few minutes from the Spanish school. He and Eileen walked to the house to see if Chris and Lisanne were there and had perhaps got their times mixed up.
西班牙语学校等待莉桑·弗伦和克里斯·克雷默。前一天早上，这两位荷兰游客预订了费利西亚诺的导游服务，去参观附近的一个农场。一位在西班牙语学校工作的德国女性艾琳（Eileen）也决定加入她们。但随着时间一分一秒过去，莉桑和克里斯却不见踪影。费利西亚诺知道这两位年轻女性住在距离西班牙语学校仅几分钟路程的一户人家里。他和艾琳步行到那所房子，看看克里斯和莉桑是否在那里，或者是否记错了时间。
No one appeared to be home and the curtains to the guest room were pulled shut. Feliciano phoned the homeowner, a woman named Miriam, to ask if she knew where the Dutch women could be. Miriam had no idea. She said that Chris and Lissane were still out when she went to bed the previous evening. She hadn't seen them that morning either, but had left them breakfast before heading off to work. Miriam told Feliciano where he could find a spare key and gave him permission to go inside. He entered Chris and Lisanne's room. The room was relatively tidy and the two single beds didn't appear to have been slept in. Some of the women's personal belongings, including mobile phone charges, were spread out
家里似乎没人，客房的窗帘也拉上了。费利西亚诺给房主米里亚姆（Miriam）打电话，询问她是否知道这两位荷兰女性可能在哪里。米里亚姆毫无头绪。她说前一天晚上她睡觉时，克里斯和莉桑还没回来。她那天早上也没见到她们，但在去上班前给她们留了早餐。米里亚姆告诉费利西亚诺在哪里可以找到备用钥匙，并允许他进去。他进入了克里斯和莉桑的房间。房间相对整洁，两张单人床看起来并没有人睡过。一些女性的个人物品，包括手机充电器，散落在
across their beds and the bedside table while the rest of their luggage was packed away into the cupboard. Wherever Lisan and Chris were, the state of their room indicated that they didn't intend to be gone for long. Feliciano and Eileen reasoned that the pair had likely changed their plans last minute without informing anyone. They decided to check in later that day to make sure all was well. By the time Miriam returned home from work, the breakfast she'd put out for her guests remained untouched. By sundown, Lysanne and Chris still hadn't returned to Miriam's, nor had they contacted
床上和床头柜上，而其余的行李则收拾在柜子里。无论莉桑和克里斯在哪里，房间的状态表明她们并不打算离开太久。费利西亚诺和艾琳推测，两人很可能在最后一刻改变了计划而没有通知任何人。她们决定当天晚些时候再来看看，以确保一切安好。当米里亚姆下班回家时，她为客人们准备的早餐依然原封不动。日落时分，莉桑和克里斯仍未回到米里亚姆家，也没有联系
anyone to inform them of their whereabouts. Feliciano and Eileen went to the police to report the pair missing. It was the middle of the night in the Netherlands when Lysanne's mother, Dinnie Froon, was awoken by the ringing of the phone. Fear washed over her as she was informed that her daughter had failed to return to her lodgings for the night. Dinnie and her husband Peter called the emergency number for the travel agency that had organised Chris and Lisanne's trip.
任何人告知她们的下落。费利西亚诺和艾琳去警察局报案，称两人失踪。在荷兰，莉桑的母亲迪妮·弗伦（Dinnie Froon）在半夜被电话铃声惊醒。当她得知女儿当晚没有回到住处时，恐惧席卷了她。迪妮和丈夫彼得拨打了组织克里斯和莉桑旅行的旅行社的紧急电话。
The woman there assured the worried parents that the girls had likely gone out for the night and would return soon. It was only when she started making some calls around Boquete on the froon's behalf that they realised the pair hadn't slept at Miriam's the previous night either. It dawned on them. Chris and Lisanne had already been missing for over 24 hours. and Lesanne had already been missing for over 24 hours. Dinny immediately went on the hunt for the Kramer's phone number. It turned out they'd been needing it after all. By the morning of Thursday, April 3, word quickly spread throughout Boquete that two young Dutch women were missing. Locals were eager to join the search, but nobody knew where to look. Chris and Lisanne hadn't told anyone what their plans were for the
那里的工作人员向焦虑的父母保证，女孩们很可能只是出去过夜，很快就会回来。直到她代表弗伦一家在博克特打了一些电话后，他们才意识到两人前一天晚上也没有在米里亚姆家睡觉。他们恍然大悟。克里斯和莉桑已经失踪超过24小时了。迪妮立即开始寻找克雷默一家的电话号码。事实证明，他们确实需要它。到4月3日星期四早上，博克特到处都在传两名年轻的荷兰女性失踪的消息。当地人急于加入搜寻，但没人知道去哪里找。克里斯和莉桑没有告诉任何人她们接下来的计划，
previous couple of days, nor had they left a note in their room, sent any texts, or written anything in their diaries about where they intended on going. Although the two had taken smartphones with them, neither device was equipped with a Panamanian SIM card. Chris and Lisanne had simply been using their phones to connect to the internet using wifi, which was how they maintained contact with loved ones back home. Mobile records gave no indication of where they could be, but a check of the internet history at the Spanish school confirmed that the pair had searched for information about a popular hiking trail known as the Pienista. A 10 minute drive outside of town, the Pienista offers visitors the opportunity to walk to the top of the continental divide.
也没有在房间里留下字条，没有发过任何短信，也没有在日记中写下她们打算去哪里。虽然两人带了智能手机，但都没有配备巴拿马SIM卡。克里斯和莉桑只是通过WiFi连接互联网来使用手机，这也是她们与国内亲人保持联系的方式。移动记录没有显示她们可能在哪里，但对西班牙语学校互联网历史的检查证实，两人曾搜索过关于一条名为“皮亚尼斯塔”（Pianista）的热门徒步小径的信息。皮亚尼斯塔距离镇中心有10分钟车程，为游客提供了步行至大陆分水岭顶部的机会。
The trail begins across open fields before weaving upwards through dense forests until it reaches the summit known as the Mirador, at roughly 6,500 feet above sea level. On a clear day, the Mirador offers a 360 degree view of the forest canopy stretching all the way to the ocean. For the healthy able-bodied individual, the Pianista can be completed within about 5-6 hours. It's a relatively straightforward, albeit challenging hike, with a single defined track taking individuals all the way to the summit and back down again.
小径穿过开阔的田野，然后蜿蜒向上穿过茂密的森林，直到到达海拔约6500英尺的被称为“米拉多”（Mirador）的山顶。在晴朗的日子里，米拉多可以360度俯瞰一直延伸到海洋的森林树冠。对于身体健康的个人来说，皮亚尼斯塔大约可以在5-6小时内完成。这是一条相对简单但具有挑战性的徒步路线，有一条明确的单行道通往山顶并返回。
Many people choose to take an experienced tour guide with them, but it's not unusual for travellers to do it without one. Feliciano Gonzalez, the tour guide who'd realised Chris and Lisanne were missing, said that he'd offered to take the pair to the Pianista, but they'd declined. Their online search history suggested that they might have decided to hike it alone. Various witnesses reported having seen a pair matching Chris and Lisanne's description heading towards the pianista on Tuesday April 1. The problem was, no one could say with utmost certainty that the women they'd seen had definitely been the missing Dutch duo. Chris and Lisanne were both white and slender, with strawberry
许多人选择带上一位经验丰富的导游，但游客独自前往也不罕见。意识到克里斯和莉桑失踪的导游费利西亚诺·冈萨雷斯说，他曾主动提出带两人去皮亚尼斯塔，但被她们拒绝了。她们的在线搜索记录表明，她们可能决定独自徒步。多名目击者报告称，在4月1日星期二看到一对符合克里斯和莉桑特征的人正前往皮亚尼斯塔。问题是，没有人能百分之百确定他们看到的就是那两位失踪的荷兰女性。克里斯和莉桑都是白人，身材苗条，留着草莓
blonde and light brown hair. They looked similar to many of the other young European backpackers who frequented the area. Complicating things further, no one knew for sure what the pair had been wearing or carrying when they left their guest house on Tuesday morning and witness descriptions of their clothing varied. One witness claimed to have seen Chris and Lisanne waiting for a taxi in town at around 1.45pm. This was supported by a taxi driver who recalled picking the pair up and dropping them off at a hostel called Casa Pedro shortly before 2pm. The hostel was about a 20 minute walk from the Pianista trailhead. According to the owner of the hostel, the duo asked about hiking the Pianista but later
金发和浅棕色头发。她们看起来和该地区许多其他年轻的欧洲背包客很像。更复杂的是，没有人确定两人在周二早上离开旅馆时穿了什么或带了什么，目击者对她们服装的描述各不相同。一名目击者声称在下午1点45分左右看到克里斯和莉桑在镇上等出租车。这一点得到了出租车司机的证实，他记得在下午2点前不久接载了两人，并将她们送到了名为“卡萨佩德罗”（Casa Pedro）的旅馆。该旅馆距离皮亚尼斯塔小径起点约20分钟步行路程。据旅馆老板说，两人询问了关于徒步皮亚尼斯塔的事，但后来
changed their mind, saying they were going to head back into town instead. On the main road in front of the hiking trail was a restaurant called Il Pianista. A restaurant employee claimed to have seen the pair heading up the trail sometime between 3 and 3.30pm. A dog belonging to the restaurant's owners often accompanied tourists on their hikes. According to the employee, the dog followed the women but returned later on, alone. A local woman claimed she saw Chris and Lisan heading up the mountain at around 4.15pm. Concerned that they weren't adequately dressed and that it was getting too late to complete the trek before dark, the woman warned the girls in Spanish not to go up the mountain
改变了主意，说她们要回镇上。在徒步小径前的主路上有一家名为“Il Pianista”的餐厅。一名餐厅员工声称在下午3点到3点30分之间看到两人正前往小径。餐厅老板的一条狗经常陪同游客徒步。据该员工称，狗跟着她们，但后来独自回来了。一名当地女性声称在下午4点15分左右看到克里斯和莉桑正上山。担心她们穿得不够，而且天黑前完成徒步太晚了，该女性用西班牙语警告女孩们不要独自上山。
alone. They didn't appear to have understood. Volunteer search teams began scouring the Pianista but found no sign of the missing women. If Chris and Lisan were indeed out there, they considered this a little unusual. Although the narrow trail was surrounded on both sides by dense forest, it was designed with tourists in mind and therefore difficult to veer off track. The vegetation surrounding the trail was thick to a point of being almost impenetrable. If one veered off course, they wouldn't be able to go very far, especially if they weren't appropriately dressed. Once hikers reached the summit, they typically turned around and headed back down the mountain the same way they came up. Had Chris or Lisan gotten injured or sick during their hike, common sense dictated that they would
她们似乎没听懂。志愿者搜救队开始搜寻皮亚尼斯塔，但没有发现失踪女性的任何踪迹。如果克里斯和莉桑确实在那里，他们认为这有点不寻常。虽然狭窄的小径两侧被茂密的森林包围，但它是为游客设计的，因此很难偏离轨道。小径周围的植被茂密到几乎无法穿透。如果有人偏离路线，她们走不了多远，尤其是如果她们穿着不当的话。一旦徒步者到达山顶，她们通常会转身，沿着上山的路下山。如果克里斯或莉桑在徒步过程中受伤或生病，常识告诉我们，她们会
have likely just stayed where they were until someone came by. The trail was managed and monitored by park rangers. Hikers passed through the trail every day, not just tourists but locals and members of the indigenous tribes that lived on the other side of the continental divide. However, the trail didn't technically end at the Mirador. On the other side of the summit, a rugged passage led off the tourist track and onto a precarious web of trails used almost exclusively by members of the indigenous Norbert tribe. This is where things became dicey. If Lassan and Chris had mistakenly decided to walk onwards, they could have gotten lost, especially if they'd miscalculated how much time they had before sundown. The trail was manageable for a
很可能留在原地直到有人经过。小径由公园管理员管理和监控。每天都有徒步者经过，不仅是游客，还有当地人和住在大陆分水岭另一侧的土著部落成员。然而，小径在技术上并没有在米拉多结束。在山顶的另一侧，一条崎岖的通道离开了游客轨道，进入了一个几乎只供诺伯特（Ngäbe）土著部落成员使用的危险小径网。这就是事情变得棘手的地方。如果莉桑和克里斯错误地决定继续前行，她们可能会迷路，尤其是如果她们误算了日落前的时间。小径在一段距离内是可行的，
while, but it eventually led into a paddock where the path became difficult to re-establish. Tour guide Feliciano Gonzalez was an expert on the Pianista. Not only did he take many tourists there, his family also owned property on the other side of the divide. Feliciano told the Dutch Broadcasting Foundation that it wasn't possible to lose track of the trail and wander into the forest without noticing. He said, What is possible and what is a risk is that you forget the time and that you keep walking that trail on and on. Had this been the case, the missing women were in danger of succumbing to dehydration, hunger, or the elements. April 1 had been a warm, clear day, but once the sun set, the temperature dropped significantly. Without appropriate gear or clothing, hypothermia posed a genuine risk.
但最终通向一个路径难以辨认的围场。导游费利西亚诺·冈萨雷斯是皮亚尼斯塔的专家。他不仅带许多游客去那里，他的家人在分水岭的另一侧也拥有土地。费利西亚诺告诉荷兰广播基金会，不可能在不注意的情况下偏离小径并误入森林。他说：“可能发生且存在风险的是，你忘记了时间，然后一直沿着那条小径走下去。”如果是这种情况，失踪的女性就有脱水、饥饿或遭受恶劣天气的危险。4月1日是一个温暖晴朗的日子，但太阳落山后，气温大幅下降。如果没有合适的装备或衣服，体温过低是一个真正的风险。
Lassan had asthma and had been struggling with a bad cough. This could have been exacerbated by changes in the altitude or exposure to the elements, which would only get worse in the coming days as the rainy season kicked in. which would only get worse in the coming days as the rainy season kicked in. Search teams traversed the other side of the summit but found no sign of the missing women there either. This added weight to the possibility that the two friends could have completed the hike without incident and disappeared thereafter. One local business owner claimed he saw two women matching the description of Chris and Lisanne coming down the mountain in the late afternoon of April 1, looking tired and grumpy. They asked for the best way to get back to Boquete.
莉桑患有哮喘，而且一直咳嗽得很厉害。这可能会因海拔变化或暴露在恶劣天气中而加剧，随着雨季的到来，这种情况在接下来的几天里只会变得更糟。搜救队穿过了山顶的另一侧，但也没有发现失踪女性的任何踪迹。这增加了两位朋友可能在没有发生意外的情况下完成了徒步，之后才失踪的可能性。一位当地企业主声称在4月1日傍晚看到两名符合克里斯和莉桑特征的女性下山，看起来又累又生气。她们询问回博克特的最佳方式。
He advised them to take a taxi, but he didn't see which direction they went or what they did from there. Back in the Netherlands, the Kramer's and Froon families did all they could from their end. They reported the disappearance to police in Amersfoort, notified Interpol, and created a Facebook page appealing for information. As the search gained momentum, the families reassured themselves that the duo would likely turn up soon with a valid explanation. But as the search reached its fourth fruitless day, concerns heightened. Panama's National Civil Protection Unit, CINAPROC, took over the mission and called for all the volunteer search parties to stand down. Working on the belief that the pair were lost in the wilderness,
他建议她们打出租车，但他没看到她们往哪个方向走，也没看到她们之后做了什么。在荷兰，克雷默和弗伦一家尽其所能。他们向阿默斯福特的警方报告了失踪事件，通知了国际刑警组织，并创建了一个Facebook页面呼吁提供信息。随着搜寻工作的推进，家人们安慰自己，两人很快就会带着合理的解释出现。但随着搜寻进入第四天却一无所获，担忧加剧了。巴拿马国家民防部门（SINAPROC）接管了任务，并要求所有志愿者搜救队撤离。基于两人在荒野中迷路的假设，
a map was created of all the possible locations that Chris and Lisanne might have visited. 25 routes throughout the Baru National Park that surrounded the Pianista were identified, with a team of 40 Sinoproc rescuers and 35 agents from the National Police tasked with conducting the search. Sniffer dogs were also brought in, but after a week of dry, clear weather, rainy conditions added an extra challenge to the already difficult exploration. It also increased the fears for Chris and Lisanne's wellbeing. While the trails could have been manageable at first, the intense rain turned them into muddy, unforgiving passageways, the babbling streams transforming into rushing rivers. Some small vacant huts along the trails could have provided adequate shelter, but these were
一张克里斯和莉桑可能去过的所有地点的地图被绘制出来。确定了环绕皮亚尼斯塔的巴鲁国家公园（Baru National Park）内的25条路线，由40名Sinaproc救援人员和35名国家警察特工组成的团队负责进行搜寻。搜救犬也被带了进来，但在经历了一周干燥晴朗的天气后，雨天给本已困难的探索增加了额外的挑战。这也增加了对克里斯和莉桑安危的担忧。虽然小径起初可能还算好走，但强降雨将它们变成了泥泞、无情的通道，潺潺的小溪变成了湍急的河流。小径沿途的一些小型空置小屋本可以提供足够的庇护，但这些都
checked and no signs were found to indicate Chris and Lisanne had stayed within. If they'd sought shelter in a cave or crevice somewhere, this would only make them more difficult to find, with any screams for help most likely being absorbed by the surrounding jungle. for help most likely being absorbed by the surrounding jungle. Members of Chris and Lisanne's families flew to Panama to join the search efforts. In a bid to encourage indigenous people from the other side of the continental divide to continue the search, they announced a two and a half thousand dollar reward. Still, the days ticked by with no leads. Some started to criticise Sinaproc's approach, calling for the search to be expanded beyond the National Park and to other areas the missing women might have headed to. If the Dutch women had made it back from the Pianista,
经过了检查，没有发现任何迹象表明克里斯和莉桑曾待在里面。如果她们在某个洞穴或裂缝中寻求庇护，这只会让她们更难被找到，任何求救的尖叫声很可能都会被周围的丛林所吞没。克里斯和莉桑家人的成员飞往巴拿马加入搜寻工作。为了鼓励大陆分水岭另一侧的土著人民继续搜寻，他们宣布了2500美元的奖励。然而，日子一天天过去，依然没有任何线索。一些人开始批评Sinaproc的方法，呼吁将搜寻范围扩大到国家公园之外，以及失踪女性可能前往的其他地区。如果这两名荷兰女性确实从皮亚尼斯塔回来了，
officials could be wasting precious time by not properly exploring other options. By April 14, two weeks had passed with no breakthroughs. If Chris and Lisanne were out in the wilderness, their chances of survival at this point were slim. The intensive search was scaled back, with the investigation handed over to the public ministry. Panamanian and Dutch authorities worked collaboratively to generate leads and provide support to the families. But as each day passed with no new information emerging, the belief that Chris and Lisanne were lost gave way to a new prevailing theory.
官员们如果不妥善探索其他选择，可能会浪费宝贵的时间。到4月14日，两周过去了，没有任何突破。如果克里斯和莉桑在荒野中，她们此时的生存几率很小。密集的搜寻工作缩减了规模，调查移交给了公共部。巴拿马和荷兰当局合作寻找线索并为家人们提供支持。但随着每一天过去，没有任何新信息出现，两人迷路的信念让位于一种新的主流理论。
That the pair had met with foul play. Casefile will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. This episode of Casefile is sponsored by BetterHelp. Is there something you need to get off your chest? Well you all carry around different stresses, big and small. That's just part of life. It's when we keep these things bottled up that they can start to affect us negatively. Therapy is a safe space where you can get things off your chest and figure out how to work through whatever's weighing you down. The team at Casefile are firm believers in the benefits of therapy. It's not just for those who have experienced major trauma. Therapy can teach you coping skills, help you set boundaries and to give you the space to explore your thoughts and feelings without judgement.
那就是两人遭遇了不测。Casefile很快就会回来。感谢您通过收听本集的赞助商来支持我们。本集Casefile由BetterHelp赞助。有什么事情需要你倾诉吗？你们每个人都承受着不同的压力，无论大小。这只是生活的一部分。当我们把这些事情憋在心里时，它们就会开始对我们产生负面影响。心理治疗是一个安全的空间，你可以在这里倾诉心声，并找出如何解决压在你心头的事情。Casefile团队坚信心理治疗的好处。它不仅仅适用于那些经历过重大创伤的人。心理治疗可以教你应对技巧，帮助你设定界限，并为你提供一个空间，让你在没有评判的情况下探索自己的想法和感受。
If you're thinking of starting therapy, consider trying BetterHelp. It's entirely online, designed for convenience and tailored to fit your schedule. Just fill out a short questionnaire to be matched with a licensed therapist. If they're not the right fit for you for any reason, you can switch therapists at any time at no extra cost. Get it off your chest with BetterHelp. Visit betterhelp.com slash case file today to get 10% off your first month. That's Better Help, H-E-L-P dot com slash case file. You'll have the confidence you need on the roads, whether they're wet or dry. Find a Michelin Tire Dealer by visiting Tire Discounter Group's Tread Experts Dealer Locator at www.tirediscountergroup.ca.
如果你正在考虑开始心理治疗，请考虑尝试BetterHelp。它完全在线，专为方便而设计，并根据你的时间表量身定制。只需填写一份简短的问卷，即可与持证治疗师匹配。如果由于任何原因他们不适合你，你可以随时免费更换治疗师。通过BetterHelp倾诉你的心声。今天就访问betterhelp.com/casefile，你的第一个月可享受10%的折扣。那是Better Help，H-E-L-P点com斜杠case file。无论路面干湿，你都能在路上拥有所需的信心。访问Tire Discounter Group的Tread Experts经销商定位器 www.tirediscountergroup.ca，查找米其林轮胎经销商。
Tire Discounter Group, Tire Discounter Group.ca. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. The possibility of foul play had been considered from the outset of the investigation, but it was only when no evidence emerged to suggest otherwise that it really started gaining traction. The foul play theory was mostly born from the belief that Chris and Lisanne would have never willingly ventured into the formidable trails on the other side of the Pianista summit. These were intelligent women who knew they were unprepared for an extended period of time in the wilderness.
Tire Discounter Group，Tire Discounter Group.ca。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供高质量的内容。遭遇不测的可能性从调查一开始就被考虑在内，但只有在没有证据表明其他情况时，它才真正开始获得支持。遭遇不测的理论主要源于这样一种信念：克里斯和莉桑绝不会自愿冒险进入皮亚尼斯塔山顶另一侧的险峻小径。她们是聪明的女性，知道自己没有为在荒野中长期生存做好准备。
As a lawyer hired by the Kramer's family later told the Daily Beast, I hiked it myself, the whole trail. I saw it with my own eyes. They would never have wanted to go on down into that hell. Furthermore, if one of the women had gotten sick or injured, it made sense to think that the other one would have managed to follow the trail back to safety. As investigative journalist Peter De Vries told Dutch current affairs program Een van Dag, it was plausible to think that one of the women could have slipped and fallen into
正如克雷默一家聘请的律师后来告诉《每日野兽报》的那样：“我自己徒步走完了整条小径。我亲眼所见。她们绝不会想去那个地狱。”此外，如果其中一名女性生病或受伤，认为另一名女性会设法沿着小径回到安全地带是合乎逻辑的。正如调查记者彼得·德·弗里斯（Peter De Vries）告诉荷兰时事节目《Een van Dag》的那样，认为其中一名女性可能滑倒并掉进
a ravine, making them difficult to find. It was less likely that this would happen to them both. Given that neither Chris, Lissane or any of their belongings had resurfaced during the search, Peter said, you have to consider the possibility that a third party had a hand in it. The search for the missing women shifted gears into a criminal investigation. There were two leading theories. The first was that Chris and Lisanne had encountered a perpetrator while hiking the pianista who had forced them down the other side of the mountain. Tourists had been robbed on the trail before, so it didn't seem far-fetched to consider that something more sinister could have taken place. The second theory was that Chris and Lisanne had
峡谷，导致难以被发现，这是合理的。两人同时发生这种情况的可能性较小。鉴于克里斯、莉桑或她们的任何物品在搜寻过程中都没有重新出现，彼得说：“你必须考虑第三方参与的可能性。”对失踪女性的搜寻转向了刑事调查。有两个主要理论。第一个是克里斯和莉桑在徒步皮亚尼斯塔时遇到了肇事者，强迫她们走下了山的另一侧。游客以前在小径上被抢劫过，所以考虑可能发生了更险恶的事情似乎并不牵强。第二个理论是克里斯和莉桑
successfully completed their hike, and it was upon their return to town that they met with Fowplay and were taken to another location. Chris's father told reporters, Chris's father told reporters, We are extremely worried. What worries us most is that somebody could have taken them away with an evil purpose. Rumours swirled that the pair could have been kidnapped for ransom, were being held captive, or had been murdered by an opportunistic predator as part of a sexually or financially motivated attack. The more extreme rumours speculated that they could have been sold by sex traffickers, taken by drug cartels, killed by organ harvesters, or fallen victim to a serial killer. Although there was no evidence to support any particular theory,
成功完成了徒步，在回到镇上时遭遇了不测，并被带到了另一个地方。克里斯的父亲告诉记者：“我们非常担心。最让我们担心的是，有人可能出于邪恶的目的把她们带走了。”谣言四起，称两人可能被绑架勒索、被囚禁，或者被机会主义的掠食者作为性或经济动机攻击的一部分而谋杀。更极端的谣言推测她们可能被人口贩子卖掉、被贩毒集团带走、被器官贩子杀害，或者成为了连环杀手的受害者。虽然没有证据支持任何特定理论，
Chris and Lisanne's families were taking no chances. With the investigation turned criminal, they began handing out flyers and plastering life-sized banners with their daughters' faces on them around Boguete. They hired a private investigator and created an organisation called The Foundation to Find Lisan and Chris, calling for donations from the public to help fund their ongoing search efforts. Appearing at an informal press conference, Peter Froon told reporters, Dear Lisan and Chris, Please know that we will stay here in Panama until you have been
克里斯和莉桑的家人没有放过任何机会。随着调查转向刑事案件，他们开始分发传单，并在博克特周围张贴印有女儿面孔的真人大小横幅。他们聘请了一名私家侦探，并创建了一个名为“寻找莉桑和克里斯基金会”的组织，呼吁公众捐款以资助他们持续的搜寻工作。在一次非正式的新闻发布会上，彼得·弗伦告诉记者：“亲爱的莉桑和克里斯，请知道我们将留在这里，直到你们被
found. We will wait as long as it takes. And we will not give up. Really, we won't. Have faith in us." Chris's mother, Rawley, refused to believe the worst had happened. To get her through the days, she repeated a mantra over and over in her head. She's alive and she will be found. She's alive and she will be found. The families increased the reward for information to $30,000. This was a significant amount in Panama, enough to ensure a comfortable life. While the previous reward was motivation for volunteers to join the search, the revised amount was intended to entice individuals to report suspicious activity
找到。无论需要多久，我们都会等待。我们不会放弃。真的，我们不会。请相信我们。”克里斯的母亲拉维（Rawley）拒绝相信最坏的情况已经发生。为了度过每一天，她在脑海中一遍又一遍地重复着一句咒语：“她还活着，她会被找到的。她还活着，她会被找到的。”家人们将提供信息的奖励提高到了3万美元。这在巴拿马是一笔巨款，足以确保舒适的生活。虽然之前的奖励是激励志愿者加入搜寻的动力，但修改后的金额旨在诱使个人举报他们
among their close circles. Dinny Froon told reporters, the coverage has to get bigger. There must be people here who know something." The boosted reward led to an influx of tips, including an unsubstantiated report that two decomposing bodies had been found in the jungle. Nothing brought investigators any closer to the truth, and with more leads trickling in, it became harder for them to stay on top of things. The people of Bokete were deeply affected by what was going on. It was a small community and they felt great sympathy for the loved ones of the missing
亲密圈子中的可疑活动。迪妮·弗伦告诉记者：“报道必须扩大。这里一定有人知道些什么。”提高的奖励导致了大量线索的涌入，包括一份未经证实的报告，称在丛林中发现了两具腐烂的尸体。没有任何东西让调查人员更接近真相，随着越来越多的线索涌入，他们越来越难以掌控局面。博克特的人民深受正在发生的事情的影响。这是一个小社区，他们对失踪者的亲人深表同情
women. As the sixth week passed without a solid lead emerging, residents organised a silent march in honour of Chris and Lisanne. The families thanked the people of Panama for their heartfelt support and announced that they'd be working closely with the newly assigned state prosecutor, Betsyda Pitti, who specialised in criminal cases. Citizens of Amersfoort also rallied behind the families, with various organisations holding fundraisers to raise money for the foundation to find Lisan and Chris. By late May, Boggette's rainy season was in full swing. Specialist rescue dogs were flown in from
女性。随着第六周过去，依然没有出现可靠的线索，居民们组织了一场无声游行，以纪念克里斯和莉桑。家人们感谢巴拿马人民的衷心支持，并宣布他们将与新指派的专门处理刑事案件的州检察官贝齐达·皮蒂（Betsyda Pitti）密切合作。阿默斯福特市民也支持这些家庭，各种组织举行筹款活动，为寻找莉桑和克里斯的基金会筹集资金。到5月下旬，博克特的雨季全面到来。专业的搜救犬从
the Netherlands, but their search was hindered by heavy rainfall. Despite these challenges, the Dutch teams trudged on for eight days, before concluding that there was nothing to indicate that Chris and Lisanne were anywhere in the mountains of Boekhete. Their parents were at a loss for what to do next. By the time the canine team returned to the Netherlands on June 4, Chris and Lisanne had been missing for over two months and not a single clue had emerged to suggest what had happened to them. If they weren't in the mountains, then where were they? Worried sick, the families decided to return to the Netherlands where they could organise more help and figure out their next steps. They didn't have to wait for long. They'd barely been home a week when finally there was the first big break in the case. Irma Mirando was a member of the indigenous Norbert tribe.
荷兰空运而来，但它们的搜寻受到了强降雨的阻碍。尽管面临这些挑战，荷兰团队还是艰难前行了八天，然后得出结论，没有任何迹象表明克里斯和莉桑在博克特的任何山上。她们的父母不知道接下来该怎么办。当犬类团队于6月4日返回荷兰时，克里斯和莉桑已经失踪超过两个月了，没有任何线索表明她们发生了什么。如果她们不在山上，那她们在哪里？忧心忡忡的家人们决定返回荷兰，在那里他们可以组织更多的帮助并弄清楚接下来的步骤。他们没等多久。他们回家才一周，案件终于有了第一个重大突破。伊尔玛·米兰多（Irma Mirando）是诺伯特土著部落的一员。
Mirando was a member of the indigenous Norbert tribe. She lived in the remote village of Alto Romero which was roughly a 12-hour trek north from the summit of the Pianista. On Wednesday June 11 2014, 10 weeks after Chris and Lisanne were last seen, Irma was washing clothes in the Rio Culebra. Known to English speakers as the Serpent River, the freshwater river earned its name for the snake-like way it spiralled through the region. Emma caught sight of something wedged between some driftwood and rocks of the riverbank. She went to take a closer look. It was a backpack. to take a closer look. It was a backpack. Inside, among other items, was an insurance card. Irma was all too aware that two Dutch women had recently gone missing from the area.
米兰达是当地土著诺贝特部落的一员。她住在偏远的阿尔托罗梅罗村，从皮亚尼斯塔山顶向北徒步大约需要12小时。2014年6月11日星期三，也就是克里斯和莉桑最后一次露面10周后，伊尔玛正在库莱布拉河洗衣服。这条淡水河在英语中被称为“蛇河”，因其像蛇一样蜿蜒穿过该地区而得名。艾玛瞥见有什么东西卡在河岸的浮木和岩石之间。她走近一看，是一个背包。里面除了其他物品外，还有一张保险卡。伊尔玛非常清楚，最近有两名荷兰女性在该地区失踪。
When she saw the name on the card, she recognised it immediately. Lisan Froon. Irma and her husband took the backpack to the home of a local cattle rancher who contacted the authorities on their behalf. The following day, a helicopter was dispatched to Outer Romero to collect the lightweight Burton-brand daypack. Save for some dirt, scratch marks and discoloration, it was in relatively good condition. One of the straps was partially loose and there were some small holes and tears, but the contents remained intact. This included Lissane's Samsung Galaxy smartphone, Chris' iPhone, Lissane's digital camera, two bras, two pairs of sunglasses, a water bottle, and $83 in cash.
当她看到卡上的名字时，她立刻认了出来：莉桑·福隆。伊尔玛和她的丈夫把背包带到了一位当地牧牛人的家中，牧牛人代表他们联系了当局。第二天，一架直升机被派往阿尔托罗梅罗取回这个轻便的伯顿牌日用背包。除了有些泥土、划痕和变色外，它状况相对良好。其中一条带子部分松脱，还有一些小洞和撕裂，但里面的东西完好无损。其中包括莉桑的三星Galaxy智能手机、克里斯的iPhone、莉桑的数码相机、两件胸罩、两副太阳镜、一个水瓶和83美元现金。
Lisan was an amateur photographer and she'd been using the Canon PowerShot SX270 camera to document their trip since the beginning. The camera contained a 16GB memory card, which was still accessible despite being exposed to water. Investigators watched with anticipation as the images began to load. The photos proved that Lisan and Chris did indeed hike the Pianista on Tuesday April 1, 2014, but the pictures didn't align with the witness sightings that had previously been provided. A taxi driver said he'd dropped the Dutch women off near the Pianista just before 2pm, with various witnesses then claiming to have seen the duo climbing up the mountain between 3 and 4.15pm. Each of the photos contained a digital
莉桑是一位业余摄影师，从旅行开始，她就一直用佳能PowerShot SX270相机记录他们的行程。相机里有一张16GB的存储卡，尽管接触过水，但仍然可以读取。调查人员满怀期待地看着照片开始加载。照片证明，莉桑和克里斯确实在2014年4月1日星期二徒步攀登了皮亚尼斯塔山，但这些照片与之前提供的目击者证词并不吻合。一名出租车司机说，他在下午2点前把这两名荷兰女性送到了皮亚尼斯塔山附近，随后有多名目击者声称在下午3点到4点15分之间看到两人在爬山。每张照片都包含一个数字
timestamp which proved that they'd actually started the hike at 11am. Straight off the bat, this debunked the timeline that investigators had been working with since the very start of the women's disappearance. From Chris and Lisanne's attire, it was clear they didn't set out for anything other than a leisurely hike. Both women were dressed in shorts and tank tops, carrying nothing between them except Lissane's backpack. They wore hiking boots but had no hats, jackets, or protective gear. Lissane captured the scenery as they made their way up the trail, with Chris often stopping to pose ahead of her. It was a bright, sunny day and the two friends looked happy. Metadata showed that they reached the Mirador summit at 1pm. A series of elated selfies captured Chris and
时间戳，证明她们实际上是在上午11点开始徒步的。这直接推翻了调查人员自两人失踪之初就一直采用的时间线。从克里斯和莉桑的着装来看，很明显她们只是去进行一次轻松的徒步旅行。两人都穿着短裤和背心，除了莉桑的背包外，什么也没带。她们穿着登山靴，但没有戴帽子、外套或防护装备。莉桑在她们沿小径向上走时拍摄了风景，克里斯经常停下来在她前面摆姿势。那是一个阳光明媚的日子，两个朋友看起来很开心。元数据表明，她们在下午1点到达了米拉多尔山顶。一系列兴高采烈的自拍捕捉到了克里斯和
Lisan grinning proudly as they gave the thumbs up symbol, showing off the epic landscape stretching behind them. Up until this point, there was nothing out of the ordinary about their actions, and their photos indicated they were alone on the trail. But from there on in, that all changed. Photos showed that Chris and Elisan did indeed travel onwards down the indigenous trails on the other side of the divide, away from Boquete. A photo taken after they'd left the summit showed Chris crossing over a stream and heading further downhill. Specialists familiar with the area identified this spot as less than an hour's hike from the top of the summit in the wrong direction. There was nothing in the pictures to
莉桑自豪地咧着嘴笑，竖起大拇指，展示着身后延伸的壮丽景观。直到这一点，她们的行为都没有什么异常，照片显示她们在小径上是独自一人的。但从那以后，一切都变了。照片显示，克里斯和莉桑确实继续沿着分水岭另一侧的土著小径前行，远离了博克特。一张在她们离开山顶后拍摄的照片显示，克里斯正在过一条小溪，并继续向山下走去。熟悉该地区的专家确定，这个地点距离山顶不到一小时的徒步路程，而且方向是错误的。照片中没有任何内容
indicate why they'd continued onwards, but some interpreted the expression on Chris's face as no longer being happy and carefree. From there, things only got stranger. For eight days, there were no more photos. Then on Tuesday, April 8 at 1.29am, the camera sprung back into action. Over a period of almost three hours, 90 similar images of near total darkness were captured. Some were taken just seconds apart, others several minutes. Only one image captured anything other than blackness. It was the back of someone's head, presumably Kris Kramer's, her long strawberry blonde hair filling the entire shot.
表明她们为什么要继续前行，但有些人解读出克里斯脸上的表情不再是快乐和无忧无虑的。从那时起，事情变得越来越奇怪。接下来的八天里，再也没有照片了。然后在4月8日星期二凌晨1点29分，相机再次开始工作。在近三个小时的时间里，拍摄了90张几乎完全黑暗的相似照片。有些照片拍摄间隔仅几秒钟，有些则间隔几分钟。只有一张照片捕捉到了除黑暗之外的东西。那是某人的后脑勺，推测是克里斯·克雷默的，她那长长的草莓金发填满了整个画面。
In a bid to make sense of the night time photos, investigators resized the images and manipulated their brightness levels. Although they were still dark, this allowed them to make out some of the items in the frame. Numerous bright specks indicated it had been raining at the time the photos were taken, which aligned with the recorded weather patterns from the time in question. Several of the images captured what appeared to be trees, foliage, moss-covered rocks and large boulders. In one photo, a twig with red plastic attached to it had been placed on the
为了弄清楚这些夜间照片，调查人员调整了图像大小并处理了亮度。尽管它们仍然很暗，但这使他们能够辨认出画面中的一些物品。无数明亮的斑点表明照片拍摄时正在下雨，这与当时记录的天气模式相吻合。其中几张照片捕捉到了看起来像是树木、树叶、长满苔藓的岩石和巨大的巨石。在一张照片中，一根系着红色塑料的树枝被放置在
rock face, seemingly intentionally, like some kind of marker. Another photo captured several pieces of what looked like intentionally torn up rubbish sitting on the rock face. From the positioning of the angle, it appeared that the photos had been taken by someone who was either sitting or lying down and facing the camera slightly upwards. Most of the images had been taken with a steady hand, indicating they were intentional and not taken under duress. The natural surroundings suggested the images had been taken on a riverbed or cliff face, but there was no clear landmark to indicate exactly where. A straight line visible in some of the photos was speculated to be a cable from one of the
岩面上，似乎是有意为之，像某种标记。另一张照片捕捉到了几块看起来像是故意撕碎的垃圾，放在岩面上。从角度位置来看，照片似乎是由一个坐着或躺着的人拍摄的，且面朝相机略微向上。大多数照片都是在手持稳定的情况下拍摄的，表明它们是有意拍摄的，而不是在胁迫下拍摄的。自然环境表明这些照片是在河床或悬崖面上拍摄的，但没有明确的地标来指出具体位置。在一些照片中可见的一条直线被推测是其中一座
few makeshift bridges, known as monkey bridges, used by the indigenous locals to cross from one side of the Serpent River to the other. This bridge was deep into the forest, several miles from where the last photo of Chris was taken on April 1. With the back of Chris' head visible in one shot, it was plausible to assume Lisan was the one taking the photos. But this couldn't be said with certainty as she didn't appear in a single image. Furthermore, because Chris's face wasn't visible, there was nothing to prove what kind of state she
简易桥梁的缆绳，被称为“猴桥”，是当地土著用来从蛇河一侧穿过到另一侧的。这座桥位于森林深处，距离4月1日拍摄克里斯最后一张照片的地方有几英里远。由于其中一张照片中可以看到克里斯的后脑勺，因此可以推测是莉桑在拍照。但这不能确定，因为她没有出现在任何一张照片中。此外，由于看不到克里斯的脸，没有任何证据证明她当时处于什么状态
was in or that she was even alive at the time the photo was taken. A whole week had passed between the last photo of Chris crossing the stream and the night time images, yet Chris's hair appeared clean and dry. Nothing in the photos or the backpack presented a single clue as to what had happened to the women during that unaccounted for chunk of time. If they had gotten lost or injured, why suddenly take 90 photos a week later, in the middle of the night no less? Some of the mysterious night time photos were published in the media, prompting a deluge of theories from members of the public as to what they could mean. Theories ranged from the practical
或者她在那张照片拍摄时是否还活着。从克里斯过溪的最后一张照片到夜间图像之间已经过去了一整周，但克里斯的头发看起来干净且干燥。照片或背包中没有任何线索能解释在那段无法解释的时间里，这两个女人发生了什么。如果她们迷路或受伤了，为什么一周后在半夜突然拍摄了90张照片？一些神秘的夜间照片在媒体上发布，引发了公众对这些照片含义的大量猜测。理论范围从实际的
to the supernatural, with many comparing the images to scenes from the supernatural horror film, The Blair Witch Project. Some speculated that Lissane could have been using the flash of her camera as a source of light and had simply been taking the photos to get a better view of her surroundings. The problem with this theory was that the images had all been taken from practically the same spot. The photographer didn't seem to be attempting to move or find their way around. Others speculated that Lisan or Chris could have been using the flash of the camera to signal for help.
到超自然的，许多人将这些图像与超自然恐怖电影《女巫布莱尔》中的场景进行了比较。一些人推测，莉桑可能一直在使用相机的闪光灯作为光源，只是为了更好地观察周围环境而拍摄了这些照片。这个理论的问题在于，这些图像几乎都是在同一个地点拍摄的。摄影师似乎并没有试图移动或寻找出路。其他人推测，莉桑或克里斯可能一直在使用相机的闪光灯发出求救信号。
But this didn't explain why the images had been taken from underneath foliage. If the women were trying to grab someone's attention, it made sense to assume they would have moved out into the open if they were physically able to. Others theorised that Chris and Lisanne knew they were about to die and were taking the photos as some kind of message to whoever found the camera. But Lisanne's camera had plenty of battery life left on it and was also capable of taking videos. If they were on the brink of death, why not take a clearer photograph or record a message for their families explaining what
但这并不能解释为什么这些图像是在树叶下拍摄的。如果她们试图引起某人的注意，假设她们在身体允许的情况下会移动到开阔地带是合理的。其他人推测，克里斯和莉桑知道她们快要死了，拍摄这些照片是作为给发现相机的人留下的某种信息。但莉桑的相机电池电量充足，而且还能录制视频。如果她们处于死亡边缘，为什么不拍一张更清晰的照片或录下一段给家人的信息，解释发生了什么
had happened to them? With no such message, this led to the more sinister theories. What if it wasn't Lisan or Chris who took the photos at all, but someone else entirely? Casefile will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. The new Michelin Defender 2 tyre is designed to outlast. With a quiet and comfortable ride, you'll have the confidence you need on the roads, whether they're wet or dry. Find a Michelin Tire Dealer by visiting Tire Discounter Group's Tread Experts Dealer Locator at TireDiscounterGroup.ca slash locations.
对她们来说呢？由于没有这样的信息，这导致了更险恶的理论。如果拍照的根本不是莉桑或克里斯，而是完全是别人呢？Casefile节目稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本期节目的赞助商来支持我们。新款米其林Defender 2轮胎专为持久耐用而设计。凭借安静舒适的驾驶体验，无论路面干湿，您都能在道路上获得所需的信心。请访问Tire Discounter Group的Tread Experts经销商定位器（网址为TireDiscounterGroup.ca/locations）查找米其林轮胎经销商。
Tire Discounter Group, TireDiscounterGroup.ca Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. With none of the photos providing any definitive answers about what happened to Chris Cramer's and Lisanne Froon, all possibilities remained open. With the discovery of the backpack, at the very least, investigators now had a specific area to hone in on. The portion of the Serpent River near Alto Romero was particularly difficult to reach and even harder to navigate. While members of Sinaproc were dispatched to join the search, a team of locals from the Norbear tribe led by tour guide Feliciano Gonzalez also began scouring the area,
Tire Discounter Group, TireDiscounterGroup.ca 感谢您收听本期节目的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供优质内容。由于没有任何照片能就克里斯·克雷默和莉桑·福隆身上发生的事情提供任何明确的答案，所有的可能性仍然存在。随着背包的发现，调查人员至少现在有了一个可以重点关注的具体区域。阿尔托罗梅罗附近的蛇河河段特别难以到达，也更难航行。虽然Sinaproc的成员被派去参加搜救，但由导游费利西亚诺·冈萨雷斯带领的一队诺贝特部落当地人也开始搜寻该地区，
as they knew the forest better than anyone. Just days after the backpack was recovered, on Wednesday June 18, they were scouring the riverbank a little further upstream from where the backpack was found when they were hit with a distinct smell. Following the odour behind a tree, they found a woman's hiking boot, its laces still tied, and the intact remains of a left foot inside. On the other side of the riverbed was the left part of a human pelvis bone. While the bones were taken away for forensic testing, a member of the Norbert search party headed further up the river, back towards the second monkey bridge in the area.
因为他们比任何人都更了解这片森林。在背包被找回仅仅几天后，即6月18日星期三，当他们在发现背包地点上游一点的河岸进行搜寻时，闻到了一股刺鼻的气味。顺着气味在一棵树后，他们发现了一只女式登山靴，鞋带仍然系着，里面还有一只完整的左脚残骸。在河床的另一侧是人类骨盆的左侧部分。当骨头被带走进行法医鉴定后，诺贝特搜救队的一名成员沿着河流进一步向上游走，回到了该地区的第二座猴桥。
There, they found Chris Kramer's denim shorts, unzipped and unbuttoned. Reports differ as to where exactly this discovery was made and whether the shorts were in the water or on the riverbank. Regardless, it led to the question of how they came to be there. Had Chris intentionally taken them off for some reason? Had she fallen while attempting to cross the river? or had they been forcibly removed? DNA testing confirmed that the foot was Lissane Froon's. The broken pelvic bone was later confirmed to have come from Chris Kramer's. With confirmation that the duo were deceased, but still nothing to clarify what happened
在那里，他们发现了克里斯·克雷默的牛仔短裤，拉链和纽扣都解开了。关于这一发现的具体位置以及短裤是在水中还是在河岸上，报告各不相同。无论如何，这引出了它们是如何出现在那里的问题。克里斯是出于某种原因故意脱掉它们的吗？她在试图过河时摔倒了吗？还是它们被强行脱掉了？DNA检测证实那只脚是莉桑·福隆的。破碎的骨盆后来被证实来自克里斯·克雷默。随着两人死亡的确认，但仍然没有任何线索来澄清发生了什么
to them, the investigation was declared a crime against personal integrity. For the families, this news was met with mixed feelings. On one hand, they were relieved to finally have some answers about where the two women had ended up. On the other hand, they were plagued by questions about how they got there and who or what caused their deaths. The families announced that they intended to continue the search until it became clear what happened. A statement released on their behalf said, too many questions remain unanswered for the families to find peace of mind. Too little has been uncovered from Chris and Lisanne to give up the search or to be able to say their farewells. We will focus our attention
对她们来说，调查被宣布为针对个人完整性的犯罪。对于家属来说，这个消息让他们心情复杂。一方面，他们终于松了一口气，对这两个女人最终的下落有了一些答案。另一方面，他们被关于她们是如何到达那里以及是谁或什么导致了她们死亡的问题所困扰。家属宣布，他们打算继续搜寻，直到弄清楚发生了什么。代表他们发表的一份声明说，对于家属来说，太多的问题仍然没有答案，无法让他们安心。关于克里斯和莉桑的信息发现得太少，无法放弃搜寻或能够说再见。我们将把注意力集中在
on two different aspects of the search. What exactly happened to Chris and Lisanne and what can we recover from them? We want to figure out what exactly happened to them and whether third parties have been involved." With poor weather hindering the search of the already inhospitable area, the parents said they were waiting to see what data could be recovered from their daughter's electronics. They thanked the public, media and Panamanian authorities for their ongoing support, but requested that the press refrain from speculation and stick to the facts. It took weeks before any usable data could be extracted from the smartphones belonging to Chris and Lisanne.
搜寻的两个不同方面。克里斯和莉桑到底发生了什么，我们能从她们身上找回什么？我们想弄清楚她们到底发生了什么，以及是否有第三方参与其中。”由于恶劣的天气阻碍了对本已荒凉地区的搜寻，父母们表示他们正在等待看能从女儿的电子设备中恢复什么数据。他们感谢公众、媒体和巴拿马当局的持续支持，但要求媒体不要进行猜测，坚持事实。在从克里斯和莉桑的智能手机中提取出任何可用数据之前，花费了数周时间。
When it finally was, this only raised more questions. The last photo of Kris Kramer's, which showed her walking onwards down the mountain, had been taken at 1.54pm on April 1, 2014. Call logs revealed that at 4.39pm, Kris' iPhone was used to call 112, the International Emergency Services number for the European Union. This emergency number was designed to be accessible even without a SIM card and also worked overseas, but the call failed to connect due to lack of reception. 12 minutes later, Lissande's Samsung was also used to call 112. This too was unsuccessful.
当最终提取出来时，这只会引发更多的问题。克里斯·克雷默的最后一张照片显示她正沿着山路继续行走，拍摄于2014年4月1日下午1点54分。通话记录显示，下午4点39分，克里斯的iPhone被用来拨打112，这是欧盟的国际紧急服务号码。这个紧急号码被设计为即使没有SIM卡也可以访问，并且在海外也能使用，但由于缺乏信号，通话未能接通。12分钟后，莉桑的三星手机也被用来拨打112。这也失败了。
Both phones were switched off shortly after. Investigators failed to make sense of this. The call logs indicated that something bad must have happened in the two and a half hours between the last photo being taken and the first emergency call being placed. But nothing on the camera or the phones indicated what that could have been. This raised the question, what could be serious enough to warrant calling emergency services, waiting 12 minutes before trying again, and then giving up entirely? The following morning, on April 2, both phones were powered back on and used to call both 112 and the local emergency number 911.
两部手机在不久后都被关机了。调查人员无法理解这一点。通话记录表明，在拍摄最后一张照片和拨打第一个紧急电话之间的两个半小时内，一定发生了什么糟糕的事情。但相机或手机上没有任何内容表明那可能是什么。这引出了一个问题：什么事情严重到需要拨打紧急服务电话，等待12分钟后再试一次，然后完全放弃？第二天早上，即4月2日，两部手机都被重新开机，并被用来拨打112和当地紧急号码911。
Again, the calls failed due to lack of reception and were switched back off. Lissane's phone was switched on that evening and left on overnight, but no further calls were made from this device. It was turned on and off intermittently the following day, before the battery went flat on the morning of April 4. Chris's iPhone made its last attempt to call 911 on the morning of April 3. After that, it was switched on and off a few times each day, presumably seeking a signal, but no calls were made and at no point did it connect with a local cell phone tower.
同样，由于缺乏信号，通话失败，手机再次被关机。莉桑的手机在当晚被开机并保持开机状态过夜，但该设备没有再拨打任何电话。第二天它被间歇性地开关机，直到4月4日早上电池耗尽。克里斯的iPhone在4月3日早上最后一次尝试拨打911。此后，它每天被开关机几次，推测是在寻找信号，但没有拨打任何电话，也没有在任何时候连接到当地的手机信号塔。
A PIN code was needed to access Chris' iPhone. On the morning of April 5, the PIN code was entered correctly for the last time. That night and the following day of April 6, the iPhone was turned on and off, but the correct PIN code was never punched in again. The phone remained off for the next five days, including on April 8, the date the unexplained night photos were taken. On April 11, the iPhone was switched back on at 10.50am without the PIN code being entered. An hour later, at 11.50am, the iPhone was turned off for good despite still having battery power.
访问克里斯的iPhone需要PIN码。4月5日早上，PIN码最后一次被正确输入。那天晚上和第二天4月6日，iPhone被开关机，但正确的PIN码再也没有被输入过。手机在接下来的五天里一直处于关机状态，包括4月8日，即拍摄神秘夜间照片的那一天。4月11日上午10点50分，iPhone在没有输入PIN码的情况下被重新开机。一小时后，即上午11点50分，尽管仍有电量，iPhone还是被永久关机了。
Neither of the phones contained any clues such as goodbye messages, unsent texts or voice memos, to explain what had happened after the women crossed the Mirador. Investigators couldn't figure out why the attempts to use the phones had been so sporadic. Had Chris and Lisanne been in genuine trouble, one would assume there would have been more attempts to get service and call for help earlier on. And why, all of a sudden, was Chris' PIN code no longer entered correctly? Was this simply because she switched the phone on and then off again upon realising she couldn't get a signal? Or was it because Chris herself was no longer in possession of the phone? If Chris had perished and Lisanne was in fact the one trying to use the iPhone, how did that explain photos of the back of Chris' head taken three days
两部手机都没有包含任何线索，如告别信息、未发送的短信或语音备忘录，来解释女性穿过米拉多尔后发生了什么。调查人员无法弄清楚为什么使用手机的尝试如此零星。如果克里斯和莉桑真的遇到了麻烦，人们会认为她们会更早地尝试获取服务并寻求帮助。而且，为什么克里斯的PIN码突然不再被正确输入了？这仅仅是因为她在意识到无法获得信号后打开了手机，然后又关掉了它吗？还是因为克里斯本人已经不再持有这部手机了？如果克里斯已经遇难，而莉桑实际上是试图使用iPhone的人，那怎么解释三天后拍摄的克里斯后脑勺的照片呢？
later? It wasn't just the phone data that had investigators scratching their heads. As the Dutch team scrutinised the data from Lisanne's camera, they realised that one image was missing from the sequence. The image of Chris crossing the stream on the afternoon of April 1 had been labelled as photo number 508. Photo number 510 was the first of the nighttime shots taken on April 8. 10 was the first of the night time shots taken on April 8. Photo 509, the image that bridged the gap between the normal daytime photos and the mysterious night time photos, was missing. When a photo is manually deleted off a digital camera, the file can usually be restored using special software when connected to a computer. Despite significant efforts, the Dutch experts were unable to restore deleted image 509. Analysis of Lisanne's camera
不仅仅是手机数据让调查人员抓耳挠腮。当荷兰团队仔细检查莉桑相机中的数据时，他们意识到序列中缺少了一张照片。4月1日下午克里斯过溪的照片被标记为第508号照片。第510号照片是4月8日拍摄的第一张夜间照片。第509号照片，即连接正常白天照片和神秘夜间照片的图像，丢失了。当照片从数码相机中手动删除时，连接到计算机后通常可以使用特殊软件恢复文件。尽管付出了巨大努力，荷兰专家仍无法恢复已删除的第509号图像。对莉桑相机的分析
determined she wasn't in the habit of deleting photos herself, even if they weren't the best shots, so it seemed unlikely that she had deleted it on purpose. Speaking to the Afrotros TV network, one Dutch investigator said, Photo 509 could give us a clue as to what happened, and it is a real shame that we have not been able to retrieve anything from this photo. We do not know when this photo was taken, whether on April 1st or at another moment in time, or why it was deleted. A glitch in the system seemed unlikely, as experts could typically restore at least a fraction of a deleted photo. This led to speculation that it could have been permanently deleted by Panamanian investigators who first
确定她没有自己删除照片的习惯，即使它们不是最好的照片，所以她故意删除它的可能性似乎不大。在接受Afrotros电视网采访时，一名荷兰调查员说：“第509号照片可以给我们提供关于发生了什么的线索，非常遗憾的是我们没能从这张照片中找回任何东西。我们不知道这张照片是什么时候拍摄的，是在4月1日还是在其他时间，也不知道它为什么被删除。”系统故障似乎不太可能，因为专家通常至少可以恢复已删除照片的一小部分。这导致人们猜测它可能是被最初接触相机的巴拿马调查人员永久删除的，
had access to the camera, either by accident or on purpose. Boquete's economy relied on tourism. If the pitcher captured something incriminating that could deter people from visiting the area, some believed the authorities had a good reason to want to keep it quiet. By late August 2014, several more bones were found scattered further downstream of the Serpent River. One was confirmed to have come from Chris Kramer's right rib, while two others were identified as Lysand Frun femur and tibia.
无论是意外还是故意。博克特的经济依赖旅游业。如果照片捕捉到了什么可能阻止人们访问该地区的罪证，一些人认为当局有充分的理由想要保持沉默。到2014年8月下旬，在蛇河下游又发现了更多散落的骨头。其中一块被证实来自克里斯·克雷默的右肋骨，而另外两块被鉴定为莉桑·福隆的股骨和胫骨。
No official reports have ever been released regarding the autopsies, but some of the information has been leaked to the media by anonymous sources. Dutch author Juergen Snorren was given access to the full case file while researching the story for a book he co-wrote called Lost in the Jungle. According to Jurgen, Lisanne's metatarsal bones, the small bones at the forefront of her foot, were fractured in three places. Signs of healing indicated these fractures had occurred while Lisanne was still alive. Both of her leg bones showed signs of periocitis.
关于尸检的官方报告从未发布，但一些信息已被匿名来源泄露给媒体。荷兰作家尤尔根·斯诺伦在为他合著的一本名为《迷失在丛林中》的书研究故事时，获得了查阅完整案卷的权限。据尤尔根说，莉桑的跖骨，即她脚前部的小骨头，在三个地方骨折。愈合的迹象表明这些骨折发生在莉桑还活着的时候。她的两根腿骨都显示出骨膜炎的迹象。
This condition is caused by repetitive stress and it results in inflammation of the tissue surrounding the tibia. Symptoms include intense pain, limited mobility, fever, and chills. Combined with the broken bones in her feet, this meant Lisan wouldn't have been able to walk very far after sustaining the injuries. But what caused those injuries and when remained up for speculation. The marrow in Lissane's leg bones was still intact, indicating the bones were only in the early stage of decomposition. This was in stark contrast to the condition of Chris's rib bone, which was pale white, or what some describe as being bleached. Bone bleaching can be caused by two things, extended exposure to sunlight, or exposure to a chemical such as lime. Lime can occur naturally
这种情况是由重复性压力引起的，会导致胫骨周围组织发炎。症状包括剧烈疼痛、活动受限、发烧和寒战。加上她脚部的骨折，这意味着莉桑在受伤后不可能走得很远。但导致这些伤害的原因以及时间仍然是猜测的对象。莉桑腿骨中的骨髓仍然完好无损，表明骨头仅处于分解的早期阶段。这与克里斯肋骨的状况形成了鲜明对比，后者呈苍白色，或者有些人描述为被漂白了。骨骼漂白可以由两件事引起：长时间暴露在阳光下，或暴露在石灰等化学物质中。石灰可以在自然界中自然存在
in the environment and is a key ingredient in fertil fertilizer, but it can also be used in criminal cases to speed up human decomposition. None of the bones provided a clear indication as to what caused Chris or Lissane's death. Lissane's autopsy determined that her broken metatarsal bones were likely caused by a fall from a high place, but this couldn't be said with certainty. Such injuries can also result from repeated stress or by being crushed with a hard object. Breaks like the one in Chris's pelvis could also be attributed to a fall from a great height, but this bone showed no signs of healing, indicating she was likely already dead when this injury occurred. Ultimately, none of the bones showed any signs of violence. This detail, combined with the data from the camera and phones, gave the Panamanian authorities
并且是肥料的关键成分，但它也可以在刑事案件中用于加速人体分解。没有任何骨头能明确指出导致克里斯或莉桑死亡的原因。莉桑的尸检确定她破碎的跖骨很可能是从高处坠落造成的，但这不能确定。此类伤害也可能由重复压力或被硬物挤压引起。像克里斯骨盆那样的骨折也可以归因于从高处坠落，但这块骨头没有显示出愈合的迹象，表明她在受伤时很可能已经死亡。最终，没有任何骨头显示出暴力的迹象。这一细节，加上相机和手机的数据，给了巴拿马当局
enough information to release an official ruling. They determined that Kris and Lissane had likely gotten lost after venturing onwards past the peak of the Pianista. At some point, they either fell to their deaths or succumbed to a combination of injuries, hunger, exhaustion, and the elements. Had they died near the river bank, their remains could have started to decompose before the rising water levels caused by heavy rainfall eventually reached them and carried them away. In the river, contact with rocks, boulders and scavengers eventually led to their bodies breaking into pieces and being scattered throughout. The majority of the remains likely flowed into the larger tributaries of the Changinola River, never to be recovered. The Kramer's family wouldn't accept this explanation. There were
足够的信息发布官方裁定。他们确定克里斯和莉桑很可能在越过皮亚尼斯塔山顶后迷路了。在某个时刻，她们要么坠落身亡，要么死于受伤、饥饿、疲惫和自然环境的综合影响。如果她们死在河岸附近，她们的遗骸可能在暴雨导致水位上涨最终到达并将它们冲走之前就开始分解了。在河中，与岩石、巨石和食腐动物的接触最终导致她们的身体破碎并散落在各处。大部分遗骸很可能流入了昌吉诺拉河的较大支流，再也没有被找回。克雷默一家不接受这种解释。有
simply too many unanswered questions. If the pair got lost, why didn't they leave anything to mark their presence on the trail? How could they have been out there for so long without crossing paths with at least one of the 20 or so locals, cattle ranchers or tour guides who passed through the area each week, while also going undetected by search parties? Chris's parents, Hans and Rorley, hired a local team and set out on a hike over the Pianista to see it with their own eyes. They concluded there was no way Chris and Lissane could have gotten lost that first day, even if they'd ventured a few hours beyond the summit. To them, the trail was clear the entire way, and there was nowhere one could sustain an
太多的问题没有答案。如果两人迷路了，为什么她们没有留下任何标记来表明她们在小径上的存在？她们怎么可能在外面待了那么久，却没有遇到每周经过该地区的20多名当地人、牧牛人或导游中的任何一个，同时也没有被搜救队发现？克里斯的父母汉斯和罗莉雇佣了一个当地团队，出发徒步越过皮亚尼斯塔山，亲眼看看。他们得出的结论是，克里斯和莉桑不可能在第一天就迷路，即使她们在山顶之外走了几个小时。对他们来说，小径全程都很清晰，而且在与紧急呼叫一致的时间范围内，没有任何地方可以让人遭受
immobilising fall in a timeframe consistent with the emergency calls. They didn't discount the possibility that Chris and Lisanne had first called emergency services because they'd crossed paths with someone with criminal intent. A forensic anthropologist who worked on the investigation also disagreed with the official ruling. Speaking anonymously to the Daily Beast, they said that the bones showed no signs of animal scavenging or any marks to indicate they'd been broken up by river rocks. They didn't believe it was possible that the bodies could have become completely detached within just seven or eight weeks, or that Chris's remains had been exposed to sunlight long enough for bleaching to have occurred naturally. As another forensic expert told the Daily Beast, an American
导致无法行动的坠落。他们并没有排除克里斯和莉桑最初拨打紧急服务电话是因为她们遇到了有犯罪意图的人的可能性。参与调查的一名法医人类学家也不同意官方裁定。在匿名接受《每日野兽》采访时，他们表示，骨头没有显示出动物食腐的迹象，也没有任何迹象表明它们是被河石撞碎的。他们不相信尸体能在短短七八周内完全分离，也不相信克里斯的遗骸在阳光下暴露的时间足够长，以至于发生了自然漂白。正如另一位法医专家告诉《每日野兽》的那样，一名美国
hiker who died in the St Forest under similar circumstances was found two years after going missing. His skeleton was still 90% intact and none of his bones showed any signs of bleaching. The only explanation, some argued, was human intervention. The Kramer's urged the Panamanian authorities to hold on to Chris's remains and keep the case open until more thorough conclusions could be drawn. Meanwhile, Lisan Froon's remains were returned to the Netherlands and she was formally laid to rest, with her family saying it was with great pain in their hearts that they had to let Lisan go. The Kramer's felt that enough of Chris' remains hadn't yet been found to warrant a burial, with her mother telling Dutch reporters,
徒步旅行者在类似情况下死在圣森林中，在失踪两年后被发现。他的骨架仍然有90%完整，他的骨头没有任何漂白的迹象。一些人认为，唯一的解释是人为干预。克雷默一家敦促巴拿马当局保留克里斯的遗骸，并保持案件开放，直到得出更彻底的结论。与此同时，莉桑·福隆的遗骸被送回荷兰，她被正式安葬，她的家人说，他们怀着极大的痛苦不得不让莉桑离开。克雷默一家觉得克里斯的遗骸还没有被发现足够多，不足以进行葬礼，她的母亲告诉荷兰记者，
It is very difficult to say goodbye when you have so little of your daughter and when you have the feeling that more is to be found. In January 2015, a Dutch forensic team travelled to Panama at the request of the Kramer's family. Aided by local guides and sniffer dogs, they followed the trail Chris and Lisanne were known to have walked, and they too concluded it was highly unlikely the pair had gotten lost. Lead investigator Frank van derhoort said,
当你只有女儿这么少的部分，并且当你觉得还有更多东西可以找到时，说再见是非常困难的。2015年1月，应克雷默一家的要求，一个荷兰法医团队前往巴拿马。在当地导游和嗅探犬的帮助下，他们沿着克里斯和莉桑已知走过的小径行进，他们也得出结论，两人迷路的可能性极小。首席调查员弗兰克·范·德霍特说，
Yet the team also ruled out foul play, concluding, The geographical conditions, the social conditions, and the technical facts as emerged from the forensic investigation make a crime in the form of a robbery, sex crime, violent crime, or kidnapping very unlikely. They determined the most probable explanation was that Lisan and Chris had slipped somewhere towards the end of the mountain's descent, landing near the riverbed, where the night photos were later taken. According to the Dutch team, quote, "...in the event of a fall at this location, there is a huge height difference of 30 to 40 meters, which makes the risk of injury very likely. height difference of 30 to 40 metres, which makes the risk of injury very likely. Moreover, the stream is surrounded on both sides by waterfalls and the bed is surrounded by a steep rock wall of several metres. They concluded that climbing out would have been near impossible without the proper tools, leading to eventual death. Given the changing water levels and the amount of time
然而，该团队也排除了谋杀的可能性，结论是：“从法医调查中得出的地理条件、社会条件和技术事实使得抢劫、性犯罪、暴力犯罪或绑架形式的犯罪非常不可能。”他们确定最可能的解释是，莉桑和克里斯在山路下降的末端某处滑倒，落在了后来拍摄夜间照片的河床附近。据荷兰团队称，引用：“……如果在这个位置坠落，会有30到40米的巨大高度差，这使得受伤的风险非常大。此外，溪流两侧被瀑布环绕，河床被几米高的陡峭岩壁包围。”他们得出结论，如果没有合适的工具，爬出来几乎是不可能的，从而导致最终死亡。考虑到不断变化的水位和自两个朋友失踪以来
that had passed since the two friends disappeared, the Dutch team deemed it unlikely that any more of their remains would ever be uncovered. Seemingly satisfied with this explanation, Chris's family announced they would finally arrange a funeral. In a statement released on their website, they said, As a family, we are relieved that we now finally have a possible and plausible explanation for all the questions we had surrounding Chris's death. We would like to thank everyone who has worked to find an answer to the question of what could happen to Chris and Lisanne since their disappearance on April 1 last year, for their dedication and commitment to achieving this result together with us.
经过的时间，荷兰团队认为她们的遗骸不太可能再被发现。似乎对这个解释感到满意，克里斯的家人宣布他们最终将安排葬礼。在他们网站上发布的一份声明中，他们说：“作为一个家庭，我们感到欣慰的是，我们现在终于对克里斯死亡周围的所有问题有了一个可能且合理的解释。我们要感谢所有自去年4月1日她们失踪以来，为寻找克里斯和莉桑身上可能发生的事情的答案而努力工作的人，感谢他们的奉献和承诺，与我们一起实现了这一结果。”
Despite this conclusion, the mysterious disappearance of Chris Kramer's and Lisanne Froon remains a hotly debated topic among reporters, amateur sleuths and forensic professionals. Even the lawyer hired by the Kramer's family, Enrique Orocha, believed something more suspicious was at play. In 2016, he told the Daily Beast, The official version of the story makes no sense. The evidence seems to have been manipulated in order to hide something. At the very least, there should have been a criminal investigation. Enrique wanted to take the case to the International Court of Justice, but the Kramer's family declined. Countless online message boards are dedicated to a wide array of theories, with individuals putting
尽管有这个结论，克里斯·克雷默和莉桑·福隆的神秘失踪仍然是记者、业余侦探和法医专业人士之间激烈争论的话题。甚至克雷默一家聘请的律师恩里克·奥罗查也认为其中有更可疑的事情。2016年，他告诉《每日野兽》：“故事的官方版本毫无意义。证据似乎被操纵了，以掩盖某些东西。至少应该进行刑事调查。”恩里克想把这个案子提交给国际法院，但克雷默一家拒绝了。无数在线留言板致力于各种各样的理论，个人投入
hours of their own time into conducting their own detailed research into various elements of the case. Every facet has been thoroughly pulled apart and examined by online sleuths, with suspicion cast on certain individuals who cropped up during the course of the investigation. Allegations that Lisan and Chris were killed by locals and the crime was then covered up by various townsfolk have been fuelled by such events as the taxi driver who claimed to have dropped the duo at the trail, also dying under suspicious circumstances just a year later. Almost every possibility has been speculated and debated, including far-fetched supernatural theories and the outlandish possibility that the pair crossed paths with cannibals.
他们自己的时间进行详细研究案件的各个要素。每一个方面都被在线侦探彻底拆解和检查，对调查过程中出现的某些个人产生了怀疑。关于莉桑和克里斯被当地人杀害，然后犯罪被各种镇民掩盖的指控，被诸如声称将两人送到小径的出租车司机在一年后也在可疑情况下死亡等事件所助长。几乎每一种可能性都被猜测和辩论过，包括牵强的超自然理论和两人遇到食人族的离奇可能性。
Proponents of the foul play theory cite various unusual elements for why they didn't accept that Chris and Lisanne died as a result of accident or misadventure. At the core is the belief that the duo wouldn't have wandered so far down the other side of the mountain at their own free will. Many believe the women were ordered down, were running away from someone, or were captured and held captive somewhere before being murdered. Others believe they left the Pianista and were then met with foul play. But as sceptics to this theory argue, what was the motive? No ransom was ever demanded and Lisanne's backpack still contained electronics and $83 in cash, ruling out theft or financial gain. If the crime was sexually motivated, why would a violent
谋杀理论的支持者引用了各种不寻常的因素，说明为什么他们不接受克里斯和莉桑是死于事故或不幸。核心信念是，两人不会自愿在山路的另一侧走得那么远。许多人认为这些女性是被命令走下去的，是在逃避某人，或者是在被谋杀前被抓获并关押在某处。其他人认为她们离开了皮亚尼斯塔山，然后遭遇了谋杀。但正如该理论的怀疑者所争辩的那样，动机是什么？从未有人要求赎金，莉桑的背包里仍然装有电子产品和83美元现金，排除了盗窃或经济利益。如果犯罪是出于性动机，为什么一个暴力的
perpetrator let them keep possession of their phones? Why didn't they destroy the camera? And how could a killer have navigated the treacherous forest while also maintaining control over two grown women and avoiding detection by the search parties. To many, if the deaths really were an accident, it simply didn't make sense that Kris and Lisan had been found in pieces, that so few of their remains had been recovered, and that they were in such varying stages of decay. How could their remains be so damaged while the possessions in their backpack were perfectly intact? Several forensic professionals, journalists and survival experts have voiced their skepticism
肇事者会让她们保留手机？为什么他们不销毁相机？杀手怎么可能在导航险恶森林的同时，还能控制两个成年女性并避免被搜救队发现。对许多人来说，如果死亡真的是一场意外，克里斯和莉桑被发现时是破碎的，她们的遗骸被找回的如此之少，而且处于如此不同的腐烂阶段，这根本说不通。她们的遗骸怎么会损坏得如此严重，而背包里的财物却完好无损？几位法医专业人士、记者和生存专家表达了他们的怀疑
about these facts. Yet, in direct contrast, others in the same fields have said the different rates of decomposition are to be expected. Talking to the Daily Beast, forensic anthropologist Dr Cathy Reichs explained that the rainforest Chris and Lassane perished in had many micro-environments. There, differences in river currents, flora growth, animal scavenging and sun exposure could result in body parts decomposing at different rates. Some resources also say that the bones did show signs of animal scavenging and that Chris's bone bleaching was well within expected natural parameters. Either way, the question remains as to why neither of the women left behind a photo, video, message or clue to explain what happened to them,
关于这些事实。然而，直接相反的是，同一领域的其他人表示，不同的分解速度是可以预料的。在接受《每日野兽》采访时，法医人类学家凯西·赖希斯博士解释说，克里斯和莉桑遇难的热带雨林有许多微环境。在那里，河流流速、植物生长、动物食腐和阳光照射的差异可能导致身体部位以不同的速度分解。一些资源还说，骨头确实显示出动物食腐的迹象，而且克里斯的骨骼漂白完全在预期的自然参数范围内。无论哪种方式，问题仍然是为什么这两个女人都没有留下照片、视频、信息或线索来解释发生了什么，
especially as the days progressed and their situation became more dire. In a case where every detail leads to more questions, many agree that the Panamanian authorities poorly handled the case from the outset. One of the biggest issues is that a proper chain of custody was never established and adequate care wasn't taken to protect the forensic integrity of the evidence. For example, it has been reported that as many as 30 foreign fingerprints were found on Lissane's backpack and belongings that were never recorded or tested. These failures, along with the lack of transparency, has led to ongoing accusations of corruption and a criminal cover-up. Adela Couriat, a journalist for leading Panamanian newspaper,
特别是在日子一天天过去，她们的情况变得更加危急的时候。在一个每一个细节都引出更多问题的案件中，许多人同意巴拿马当局从一开始就处理得很糟糕。最大的问题之一是，从未建立适当的监管链，也没有采取足够的措施来保护证据的法医完整性。例如，据报道，在莉桑的背包和物品上发现了多达30枚外国指纹，这些指纹从未被记录或测试过。这些失败，加上缺乏透明度，导致了对腐败和刑事掩盖的持续指控。阿德拉·库里亚特，巴拿马主要报纸的一名记者，
La Estrella, told the Daily Beast, quote, "...it's a sad fact, but serious investigation was never done by the public ministry. Everything had to be hushed up to protect tourism. The victims deserve justice, and the families deserve to know what really happened. Another of the major problems with this case is that over the years, many details have been either lost or misinterpreted in translation as information cycles between Dutch, Spanish and English. This, coupled with the lack of official information that has been released, has led to incorrect details being continuously regurgitated as fact, resulting in widespread misinformation. One such example is that in October 2014, an article published by La Estrella claimed that when Lissane's thigh bones were recovered,
La Estrella告诉每日野兽报：“……这是一个令人悲伤的事实，但公共部门从未进行过认真的调查。为了保护旅游业，一切都必须掩盖起来。受害者理应得到正义，家属也理应知道真相。此案的另一个主要问题是，多年来，随着信息在荷兰语、西班牙语和英语之间循环，许多细节要么丢失，要么在翻译中被误解。再加上官方发布的信息匮乏，导致不准确的细节不断被当作事实反复传播，造成了广泛的错误信息。一个例子是，2014年10月，La Estrella发表的一篇文章声称，当Lisanne的大腿骨被发现时，
a ball of her skin was also found which barely showed any signs of decomposition. However, the skin was later determined to have come from an animal. La Estrella updated their original article, but this myth about Lissande's so-called ball of skin continues to be regurgitated and used to propel speculation. Another widely misconstrued detail is that Chris's denim shorts were found zipped and neatly folded on a rock. detail is that Chris's denim shorts were found zipped and neatly folded on a rock. Dutch correspondent Mark Bessams was living in Panama when Chris and Lisanne first went missing. He explained to the Dutch Broadcasting Foundation that many of the rumours circulating around Boekhete were picked up in the Netherlands and reported by the press as proper facts. picked up in the Netherlands and reported by the press as proper facts. Mark said,
还发现了一团几乎没有腐烂迹象的皮肤。然而，后来确定那块皮肤来自动物。La Estrella更新了他们最初的文章，但关于Lisanne所谓“皮肤球”的谣言仍在不断传播，并被用来助长猜测。另一个被广泛误解的细节是，Chris的牛仔短裤被发现时是拉上拉链并整齐地叠放在岩石上的。荷兰记者Mark Bessams在Chris和Lisanne刚失踪时住在巴拿马。他向荷兰广播基金会解释说，Boquete周围流传的许多谣言被荷兰媒体采纳，并作为确凿事实进行了报道。Mark说，
"...for the first time in my career I was in the middle of a media storm. In practice, this means that you have to correct incorrect messages from the Netherlands very often. The truth is that we know few facts. As difficult as it is to accept, we simply did not know, and to this day, we simply do not know exactly what happened. Opinions on Panama's handling of this case differ as widely as the theories about what happened to the Dutch women. Lead prosecutor Betside Apiti has come under fire for what many view as a botched investigation, while others praise investigators in what's been called one of the biggest search and rescue missions ever undertaken in Panama. The Kramer's have voiced disappointment with both sides of the investigation. In 2019, Chris's father Hans told Dutch magazine Preve that he could write an encyclopedia about
“……这是我职业生涯中第一次处于媒体风暴的中心。实际上，这意味着你必须经常纠正来自荷兰的不实消息。事实是，我们掌握的事实很少。尽管很难接受，但我们确实不知道，直到今天，我们仍然不知道到底发生了什么。对于巴拿马处理此案的方式，人们的看法与关于这两名荷兰女性遭遇的理论一样分歧巨大。首席检察官Betzaida Pitti因被许多人视为拙劣的调查而受到抨击，而另一些人则称赞调查人员进行了巴拿马有史以来最大的搜救任务之一。Cremers一家对调查的双方都表示失望。2019年，Chris的父亲Hans告诉荷兰杂志《Privé》，他可以写一部百科全书来记录
all the mistakes that were made, saying, There were many loose ends. In my opinion, and that of many others, many mistakes have been made. I can still get very mad about it, but what's the point? There's no point in talking in hindsight. We have to live with the fact that our daughter is no longer here. There is still some debate about the area where the night time photos were taken. If the location designated by both the Dutch and Panamanian forensic teams is correct, it raises the haunting possibility that a search team passed by Chris and Lisanne a few days after they disappeared. At a time, their phone activity indicates at least one of them was still alive.
所有犯下的错误，他说：‘有很多悬而未决的问题。在我以及许多其他人看来，犯了很多错误。我至今仍会为此感到非常愤怒，但那又有什么意义呢？事后诸葛亮毫无意义。我们必须接受女儿已经不在了的事实。关于夜间照片拍摄地点的争论仍在继续。如果荷兰和巴拿马法医团队指定的地点是正确的，那么这就提出了一个令人不安的可能性：搜救队在她们失踪几天后曾经过Chris和Lisanne身边。当时，她们的手机活动表明至少其中一人还活着。’
In 2017, Peter Froon told BNN documentary Break Free that rescue dogs signified that they sensed something at the time, but it wasn't a strong enough indication for their handlers to pursue it. Chris' brother publicly shut this possibility down, saying the search team were only in the area weeks later, at a time when Chris and Lisanne were no longer alive. weeks later, at a time when Chris and Lisanne were no longer alive. It is understood that the Cramer's and Froon families have differing opinions about the case and have parted ways. Regardless, neither of them supported a renewed investigation, with both families choosing to move on and accept the fact that Chris and Lisanne are no longer here. When the pair were still missing, the Cramers family kept a small shrine for Chris adorned with photos, candles, and a
2017年，Peter Froon在BNN纪录片《Break Free》中表示，搜救犬当时确实表现出察觉到了什么，但迹象不够强烈，不足以让训犬员继续追踪。Chris的兄弟公开否认了这种可能性，称搜救队几周后才到达该地区，那时Chris和Lisanne已经不在人世了。据了解，Cremers和Froon两家对案件的看法不同，已经分道扬镳。无论如何，他们都不支持重新调查，两家人都选择继续生活，接受Chris和Lisanne已经不在的事实。在两人失踪期间，Cremers一家为Chris保留了一个小神龛，上面装饰着照片、蜡烛和
postcard she sent from Panama, which they called the Table of Hope. After it was confirmed that Chris was no longer alive, they maintained the shrine but renamed it Chris's Little Place. Chris's father told Privé magazine, "...We picked life back up and will think about our dear daughter every day, no matter what. Nobody can take that feeling away from us. Lissane's family accept the theory that the girls died by accident. As Lissane's brother Martijn told the hosts of the Dutch talk show Pau, if there is anything positive that I can take from this whole story, it is that they died a natural death. I do not want to think about a scenario where they ended up in prostitution,
一张她从巴拿马寄来的明信片，他们称之为“希望之桌”。在确认Chris已经去世后，他们保留了这个神龛，但将其更名为“Chris的小天地”。Chris的父亲告诉《Privé》杂志：“……我们重新开始了生活，无论如何，我们每天都会想起我们亲爱的女儿。没有人能夺走我们的这种感觉。”Lisanne的家人接受了女孩们死于意外的理论。正如Lisanne的兄弟Martijn告诉荷兰脱口秀节目《Pauw》的主持人所说，如果我能从整个故事中得到什么积极的东西，那就是她们死于自然。我不想去想她们最终沦为妓女，
or in the hands of human traffickers or something. Back when Chris and Lissane first went missing, there was nothing at the top of the Pianista summit to mark the peak of the trail. A sign has since been erected warning tourists not to go any further. Alongside it sits a memorial for Lysanne Froon and Chris Cramer's, which lists the date of their deaths as April 1, the day they went missing. Over the years, some have criticised Lysanne and Chris for making a naive decision to venture into the wilderness without taking the right precautions. The Froon family rejects this notion, instead praising the bravery the pair showed when the odds were stacked against them. Chris' brother, Martijn, told the Break Free documentary,
或者落入人口贩子之手之类的场景。当Chris和Lisanne刚失踪时，Pianista山顶没有任何标志来标示步道的终点。此后竖立了一个标志，警告游客不要再往前走。旁边是Lysanne Froon和Chris Cremers的纪念碑，上面列出的死亡日期是4月1日，即她们失踪的那一天。多年来，一些人批评Lysanne和Chris在没有采取正确预防措施的情况下冒险进入荒野，决定过于天真。Froon一家拒绝了这种观点，反而称赞了两人在面对绝境时表现出的勇敢。Chris的兄弟Martijn在《Break Free》纪录片中说：
Things are said so easily without thinking. When someone gets his wallet stolen in the centre of Amsterdam, you can't say that that person probably deserved it because he hadn't been more careful, or naive, or dumb for keeping his wallet in his pocket. Such things just happen, and a big fat bad luck. When you look closely at Chris and Lisisan's nature and in which manner they made choices in life, then I just know that they made the right decision. By deciding to take the step and go and do something beautiful. Music There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
“人们说话太容易了，根本不经过大脑。当有人在阿姆斯特丹市中心被偷了钱包时，你不能说那个人可能活该，因为他不够小心，或者太天真，或者太笨，把钱包放在口袋里。这种事情就是会发生，纯属倒霉。当你仔细观察Chris和Lisanne的本性以及她们在生活中做出选择的方式时，我就知道她们做出了正确的决定。因为她们决定迈出这一步，去追求美好的事物。”音乐：本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。